hey everybody gamespot cross kind of
funny Nick and I are checking Twitter
I'm talking Xavier woods that's where
that's where the awards went there's
your face
we literally brought you over here
leaving Brandon drafts coming on of
course the Adam from arrow he's like two
seconds behind apparently about amiibo
because I just got to go see them all on
there what amiibo did you get to talk to
touch I talked I didn't actually love if
you're talking to an amiibo we gotta we
got to talk about the big Mario yes yeah
I like if you have two versions of it
too it's pretty cool okay no no I wha
you broke my right I've only seen the
one 8-bit Mario with you well holler to
make a brighter color itself some
journalists you are major leverage your
integrity
where is your integrity gone let me
check the table okay so what have you
guys seen what are you [ __ ] hanging
out here Xavier woods from w/e that's a
great chemistry are gonna be I mean I'm
legit he's started a YouTube channel up
up down down everybody go subscribe he's
great cuz he posted any videos yeah we
just do you watched it a seventy
thousand subs this week already he's
coming for you right Queen how's the
book going good oh yeah yeah it's done
it's out we do the first book tour it
was fun yeah yeah alright that must be
an exciting time for you it's already
what are you like 21 writing your
memoirs already 21 plus 10
there's a lot of fun but uh you know to
come off the book toward and come to eat
three I mean that's just fantastic I
just play black ops yesterday gotta go
really funny cry on their shoulder about
the whole playstation thing are you
ready to accept the Vita as your lord
and savior have a Playstation no no I
mean like I get like white the Xbox on
it's got really bad right and I get why
they did right four years they've been
buying it on this platform they have
their friends they've done all this
stuff but then the business gets in the
way sometimes well I think it's gonna be
interesting how eSports is gonna handle
all of this because everybody has
already invested in Xbox yeah you know
everybody is all set up for those types
of tournaments so it's gonna completely
change the game and I think no one
really knows what's gonna happen yet so
here's my question yes you remember
Kevin the guy in the back yells at me
all the time where he's asking you to
put on your mic but I know you have to
go do you have to go you have your work
sorry all right it's fine okay I likes
Kevin for scaring her off just like all
the other girls in our life yeah monster
Kevin Felicia Day calls it disgusting
yeah I just want to know that true story
well I just want to say congrats because
you guys are doing some an amazing
coverage awesome all that quote kinda
funny about calm everybody - hi okay
well I'm gonna go I've been told Brandon
aroused incredibly close okay so
everybody will get to everyone talk in a
second so let's talk about you Nick
let's talk about these bags under my
eyes these weren't here two days ago
did you get makeup you should have
gotten I did she was like this is the
best I can do without a prosthetic she
was gonna put a whole new face on me
what did this blow my face off would've
been like the the are you caught up on
the Game of Thrones
no okay I'm not gonna say it I work when
I come to e3 I don't go watch baby
movies the many-faced God on baby iPad
yeah no no one watches it I bought the
new I the new iPad that's out now let me
cut to the wide right now cut to the
wise I have to deal with I have to do it
there it's kind of funny all did you see
your asses a thumbnail waggling spot
yeah put it towards the thing if we're
gonna do it well no no I can't rotate
the camera but they're set for a show
here that's too Ken are you giving your
last award away ok what do we do we give
our game of the Year award No
you know we have to decide okay what are
we doing that I think that's the game's
cast isn't by Justine I I mean what I
mean I wouldn't 1d I mean we ought to
decide don't we always supposed to give
it out before the show ends I know
believe it or not there's no rules or
laws regarding I thought there was like
two mandates that you're not supposed
you have to give it out before the bell
rings at five o'clock no I don't think I
don't know how we're doing it we are
inside but we're never all together I
know that's the right now the way e3 is
being run for kind of funny is that it's
like the president the vice president we
don't travel on the same plane that's
true so if anything happens it's like
right now a meteor crushes us right
calling Tim and Mary sit on our bodies
they keep the Shogun right it's perfect
yeah you went to YouTube we did we had a
great time over there played some smash
saw Burnie and Ashley in the
roosterteeth folks yeah so they're doing
a thing where you know they're they're
programming it for the YouTube stage and
obviously YouTube is pimping out their
new live platform as well as any live
gaming what was on here talking was here
phrase is a phenomenal human BAM I don't
know where you get he must eat really
well because he has a ton of energy I
mean I like Jay he's built he's he works
out clear have you been look my
prescriptions ready for reef oh oh go
get your prescription have you been over
to the the receive stage yet the YouTube
stage yet I passed it on my way to the
indicate count how many people are
incredibly buff over there it's it's
staggering
all these good-looking always gotten
power over there just like with all the
other worried about do things yeah yeah
we would never last no we would be dull
we you know we couldn't hang with that I
see his Instagram photos him travel in
the world yeah so yeah all this YouTube
Malaysia's and what nowadays like it's
like he's like a Bond villain it's just
going everywhere setting up his
syndicate of power it's true and
prestige good thing we're in there were
in like Flynn with YouTube we're fine oh
yeah youtube.com slash kind of funny if
I have to kill someone for his I'll do
it
oh yeah I don't mind if he's like I can
get you another not even another hundred
thousand subscribe right if he's like
will if you'd kill somebody will give
you the silver buttons your own yeah
don't think I've forgotten YouTube that
I got one one hundred thousand view
channels I want the silver buttons to
put on the walls of my house Brandon is
here we've got confirmation that Brandon
is in the building
hey don't worry good to see ya hi
Nick that's Greg yes is gonna go Kevin
Kevin shouts in my ear we need to mic
him up yeah the show for three days can
buy you want to fight me Kevin I'll kill
you Kevin Kevin get back in your hole
get back in the hole Kevin I now bring
up his mic Kevin or you want to just
keep yelling at people I tell you what
brand around easy this Kevin no Kevin
fella you're used to scatter stickers in
the back there Kevin wave it Brandon
round hey Kevin thanks for getting me
here that Kevin right there yeah yeah
how you doing I'm good thank you for
coming yeah my first III and yeah a lot
to take in I mean I've been to big
conventions and things like sure sure
but never won this cool no I mean not a
video all a video game other than
Blizzcon okay yeah it's credit brain
that's Grayson he's doing a great job
yes yeah he also got me here Kevin he's
a good guy it was it an okay thing it's
always hard trying to describe where to
go at III just someone I know doesn't
come to e3 cuz this is the bi devon Sawa
coming today - same problem I might go
to the uncharted force on by the arena
that work well I had to park all the way
on the other side like you know there's
only one parking garage left because
this place is you know a big hit it's
popular it's people know about this
thing yeah a few a few people I think
know about it yeah
so how are you I'm good what's happening
warm right now I'm sorry if you wanna
take off your shirt I'll take off my
shirt it will not be taking up not
happening that will never happened or
that is my nightmare
it is my nightmare not today so first e3
but I mean obviously been adventures
where you've been a comic-con before
you've done all that stuff are you into
gaming at all do you play I am yeah
although I was telling Grayson that you
know that I don't really do too much of
that sure well neither do I hear a good
company last three years have a two and
a half almost two year old son so so
you're getting there I'm my the extent
of my gaming is his puzzle apps yep yeah
cuz you do with one hand yeah well no I
mean because he's not playing the puzzle
right everybody I'm sorry there's some
cool stuff there you know and like jake
and the neverland pirates
on the Disney jr. app has like a side
scroller
thing and that he that's the extent of
video game what would you
out of ten go ahead and give the Brandon
Ralph a review of Jake of the pie you
know for a kid a kid is pretty great I'd
give it a probably nine days for me you
know I just finish in about 10 minutes
sure well yeah but you're you're a bit
smarter than your son I hope I hope so
for now for now that's right he
surprises me every day it's been
exciting freely I mean he's gonna grow
up and he's probably gonna want to come
here one day yeah totally I want to be
in this building when this happens
because this is not this is never gonna
stop he's gonna outlive all of us
fortunately Oh take us over we'll be in
the video game RDR I don't want to do
the suture yeah well you know the cool
thing you know then I think about with
ya my son is need to be awesome to play
video games that's what I always wanted
with to my dad to play you know he'd
come down dad come play rad racer with
me you know Excitebike yeah your
brothers what's he do for like five
minutes and then you know he was done my
parents for the same way yeah you you
desperately wanted a play or two and
they try to you yours whaling on them
cuz they don't even know what they're
doing yeah so this will be you know it
I'll have to watch myself as well
because my wife will say okay game times
over I'm like no no we just have to
finish this level yeah
the save point honey ready can go to bed
Zak we can't waste the effort that we
made right here so but I'm gonna try to
get him all the geeky stuff and see if
he likes it you got away like you know
I'm I like I'm like I I used to play wow
and that's too time-consuming for me
right kind of point in my life so I but
I can play hearthstone yeah and I like
magic the gathering and stuff like that
so that gets get into that some of that
stuff I think it's gonna work because
I'm pretty sure you're gonna have 3d see
stuff the rest of your life should it be
that hard if you're constantly
surrounded by Superman and arrow and
whatnot of course with my luck if I had
a kid he'd wanted me to be a lawyer that
would be it
it see that just want to be a lawyer dad
leave me alone you're such a nerd based
on my relationship with my father that
was always my concern ran a kid
cuz my dad's like super let's work on a
car and work outside you're the grass
and I'm like I want to be in the baby
that's like let's change your brakes and
I'm like or you can do that and I can
play a game but yeah I feel like that's
a that's a great part about our
generation now is because really the
last like I assume we're all roughly in
the same age range we all grew up with
it we were really the first generation
to grow up with this and this is being a
huge part of our life and now it's just
commonplace for kids right yeah I mean
imagine being a kid right now like when
I was a kid
I had to beg my mom for like a DC toy
like the one that I could find
and now you walk in and there's just
there just like temples built yeah all
of the things that we love and it's
phenomenal it must be like kids are
gonna be so much more creative now
well that and they're also you know
studies and things coming out that games
don't necessarily destroy our brains
actually can like there's some research
some more gray matter in like high high
level gamers really yeah I mean they
might have other they might be leveled
up in other places but you got your
skills your brains yes we got a
well-rounded but but you know it's more
accepted to play video games these days
and I think whereas my mom probably
thought it was rotting my brain yeah
yeah exactly go outside do so I was
trying to play you know beat Dragon
Warrior yeah yeah well if in my case it
actually was rotting my brand I had she
had to push because a lot of things
rotted your brain I don't think the
sugars more fall for rock I did that a
lot is the mainline coca-cola yeah just
before you found shadowboxing you got
you know yeah I didn't well it goes in
everything's relative
get over that side of the couch then you
start talking about real fitness over
here we're barely holding it together no
my body struggles to work everyday
that's true Brandon yes what I like the
most about you is when I announce that
you're gonna be on this show and I'm
talking to the GameSpot crew and stuff
everybody had a different touchstone for
you okay
they'd be like oh he's my favorite evil
X or Ray Palmer is coming on and then of
course Superman and stuff like that
congratulations on your career thank you
thank you I'm such a fan no I'm not even
kidding like I'm such a fan of you you
don't I mean and when you popped up on
arrow in the way you hit and how good
you are being the atom man you're you're
the levity that's show needs some
congratulations on thank you oh it's a
real joy to be able to play this
character and something I never really
expected to be in the DC Universe in
this way again you know thanks to
everyone on the you know production side
for for having be part of it you know
it's cool to get tweets or meet up with
people at conventions who say oh you you
know Adam
oh you're you played Superman yeah they
have no idea that you've played these
other characters which means you know
not necessarily the stereotype thing has
kind of gone away right I don't even
know that it also means I'm old
you're aging out these people that they
knew about you didn't even know about
there was a Superman movie ten years ago
yeah
so it's it's awesome it's great to be
known for several things and that and
then you know in this world and build
the fan base and have people enjoy it
well it's got to be fun I mean does it
does it strike you that now you are like
that world is so big now it must be fun
to be a part of that sort of big
multiverse that big cannon right we're
like you almost feel like you're I don't
even know the terms I'm looking for is
but you're you're answering into a
linear just gonna go forever now like
the dress just gonna get bigger yeah you
know it's cool thing to be a part of
something that is so big and
far-reaching and to know you know to be
a part of of a group of heroes is a neat
thing knowing that I'm not the pinnacle
nobody is the pinnacle Gary your example
yeah and we're all sharing a different
version of life like this is how this
superhero action this is how this person
acts in this given situation so we're
all prototypes archetypes for different
people right so they can all look at
themselves and say oh that's me or
that's not me but that's that's me and
that's how I how I would handle this
situation we're all giving that's what
we do in film and television is reflect
daily life as much as we can and well
that was the fun thing about when you
came onto arrow I remember they
announced it it was like okay we're like
it's Ollie show so another billionaires
coming in and you were just like you're
the light to his dark right you are
having fun with it like you know like in
the flash episode you have that great
lineup like oh great a team-up like you
like in it with the viewer of like oh
yeah this is exactly what we want yeah
definitely built on the energy and
excitement of Ray Palmer as as as the
season progressed as I you know felt
more comfortable in the role and all
those things that we kind of just
fleshed it out he really started to have
that excitement and joy and that's
what's fun for me you know III don't
think it would have taken the role if he
wasn't gonna supposed to be the the the
comic aspect to present that was what
was really exciting me about it so it's
it's like it's one of the best roles
I've got to play in a long time
was there concern when you went out for
it like you're like I'm gonna try out
for arrow but I was Superman so clearly
not gonna get this not that I wasn't
gonna get it because they weren't they
they only met with me because they were
already really inhale good right well
I'm sorry that people just come to
Brandon Rock come down not not all the
time but in this world thankfully you
know there's a my cred my previous creds
yeah give me give me something so it was
because of Samana because of Chuck and
because of the other stuff
Scott Pilgrim showing some comedic chops
yeah they really thought that this would
be a good fit for them to have me come
and be the antithesis of Oliver and and
and really bring bring the comedy
something that I didn't get to do so
much in Chuck yeah but wanted to do and
and now let's know legends of tomorrow
which is you know now you're doing
you're coasting the rest of your life we
do this for five seasons and then you
ride the college circuit the rest of
your life fine ride the college circuit
thanks to the call go to come he's not
going to colleges he could took me where
I wouldn't mind anymore the management
marry exactly know he is a married man
with a child Brandon J Ralph on Twitter
hit him up for all your collegiate
speaking opportunity so gladly come talk
to you about it yeah no uh it's just so
cool that you this worked out cuz that's
why we did a video about this and I
think this is how we actually got hooked
up the first time yeah we did the game
over Gregory show and I was always like
I loved you in Superman Returns I got
problems with the movie as a Superman
fan but you were such a great
Superman you were so great at that role
and then the fact that it just didn't
pan out the way everyone thought it was
going to I was like ah and then you came
back his arrow and Chuck obviously I
keep overlooking check for some reason
mainly cuz I just he's a super nerd
that's the problem you know if it
doesn't have a D in a sea before it he
well actually you want Rick diet coke so
that doesn't matter but anyway he only
reads comics I apologize for him going
for that like continued well that's why
Chuck hit it off I think so well with
everybody is that chuck was the comic
nerd show right that's it was like
you're talking about well I was a bad
guy so you know exactly I want to forget
I refuse to look at you in that light
that's right even the evil acts you had
redeemable qualities I understood where
you were coming from yeah yeah he wanted
he needed love I mean that's what
everybody is you know yes the
malfunction in most people's brains is
not enough love or or destroyed love in
some way and we fight back from that and
you're saying something else
that you were Donna o talking about yeah
anyway just want to say thank you for
the nice oh no please it's my Play
nice you're a very good actor and you
keep doing roles that worked for me as a
nerd so it's great to have you around so
as far as the preference is concerned is
it nice to be because you've done a lot
of films is it nice to be on a g4 TV
over film is it nice to have that sort
of like being able to come back and have
that camaraderie with your fellow cast
members I don't know if there's a
preference necessarily but there's
certainly nice things about television
and film you know I've got to play Ray
Palmer almost longer than any other
character I've ever played so that is a
cool thing to just continually grow him
and see him how he interacts with
different people on different different
conflicts yeah and my hair keeps wanting
to do this thing where it's going down
okay it looks great don't worry it's
like doing perfect hair keeps wanting to
look too perfect wide enough and I'm not
you're letting your next step to very
high pave troll if you look fine I can't
I gotta cover this button cuz it keeps
showing my belly button just take off
the shirt I'm not taking off the shirt
again my nightmare being naked in front
of Brandon Ralph is my nightmare
I'm not gonna happen not gonna happen I
would really judge you too I'm like a
big-time judge or just mark take a Marcy
like it you need better you gonna do
better work out here probably walk off
the stage
oh just kick oh you would walk on the
stage or I would have to walk up all
right like I would have to uh yeah what
do you got you got the reach he is six
five six six over there what's going on
six three get that reach but my imposing
six six you are well you have a very we
have good posture too so I feel like
that gives you a what the hell are we
talking about here anyway I get my hair
fall down and rides it it's the whole
Superman thing I try to you know oh you
don't want necessarily III that was part
of my you know not in my daily life sure
sure sure sure you want to go incognito
you're Clark Kent I can't do that anyway
it doesn't really matter yeah I can't
wear glasses I do wear glasses but I
can't it doesn't do anything for me to
hide me no see if I wear glasses I just
disappear in the crowd right like a
chameleon I could come a chameleon is
the weirdest Center you've ever had if
you I've had really weird interviews
yeah towards this one right about
WordPress what about weird press
interactions yeah what's there when I
was doing the Superman Returns press you
do all kinds of foreign press
yeah junkets and it's you know you sit
in a room and every five minutes or two
and a half minutes the so many new comes
in interviews yeah so yeah all day so it
was some spanish-speaking gentleman was
was asking me questions about like that
that the type of adult media porn yeah
suck me about that yeah and I was like
and it was kind of like almost couldn't
understand we're saying because it was
accent yeah yeah it was like um yeah I
don't I turned in my you know my
publicist I was like I think we're done
with this one yeah that's where I would
have just picked it up and run with it
well yeah you're not trying to be
Superman that's true no one expects me
to be anything but myself yeah it's just
nice yeah that's great
so what's what else what is next for you
like you've are you now you've taken
over television what's going on next
well you know we've got a film called
400 days that'll be coming out sometime
this year with caity lotz who's white
canary totally black canary like a Tom
Cavanagh who's a reverse-flash just
happened to be so it's just okay you
guys are now just this is traveling
squad we're collaborating that's genius
that's before before any of this
happened that the mobility that's we
while we were shooting a movie I then
got the meeting to meet with the arrow
producer that's awesome so yeah
craziness of life and then Dane Cook and
Ben Feldman is also in the movie it's a
sci-fi snake handler that's just kind of
fun you know mess with your head a
little bit
so four hundred days this year yeah
legends of tomorrow and comes out in
January
yeah here I'll be back on arrow for a
little bit season four leading up to two
that yeah
and doing fun stuff like this I'm doing
an awesome little spot a couple episodes
of this Comedy Central show that you
know they launch stuff from the web from
their web yes like webisodes launching
hopefully to a TV show called broken
people okay which is just bizarre and
and and fun and and that'll be out I
don't know the next
couple months you're busy and you got
this kid at home taking up all your time
well you know but but i but i enjoy that
time sure that one's good that's good
going to the park and and all that stuff
learning to swim yes oh the kid not you
yeah no i'm you mastered that one a
while yes
thankfully it's cooking him to swim stop
what up good I'm gonna compliment him on
being a good father
fine do it do it Nick clearly there
would be serial killers that's true
that's why I won't do it or in Traverse
by the way till the right time you got a
pass down the video game you lineage I
don't think that's the thing is I'm
always gonna want to play games I don't
want to be I always feel like I would be
too selfish I'd look at this kid oh my
god but that's part of the growing like
that everybody home that's part of
that's part of growing up is becoming a
little bit less selfish I refuse I
refuse they're only around for a little
while then you can go back to being your
first four years you really have to pay
attention to make sure they don't you
know fall down baby after I beat fallout
4 then and then yeah it's a four years
in there getting ready to the next one
yeah i haven't i've been really playing
any of them but the trail looks on yeah
but again you have to wait now you got
two years to wait till you have the time
to play it true yeah or just when he's
at when he's napping
sure I could I could probably do short
bursts yeah alright
but brandy Ralph yeah you are a national
treasure thank you for gracing our stage
with our idiocy and hanging out lettuce
wait how do we get a monument built in
his honor
well oh I don't know I haven't waxed I
have a wax sculpture in the Madame
Tussaud oh oh well steal that one so you
don't really I mean it's already kind of
but I want it like on my building it's
very warm right here that's I mean these
are their key nose all right everybody
Kevin is yelling and yelling Brandon
thank you so much it's a pleasure sorry
you had a run here your hair looks great
don't worry we're good
ladies and gentlemen this is gamespot
cross kind of funny
you